all right when sunday night rolls around
next week and the cowboys go to la to
play the rams we will find out
what happens during the national anthem
jerry jones the owner of the team has
not said anything over the last week and
a half about this effort to fashion a
compromise he's been on 105 3 the fan in
dallas twice since last tuesday when he
talked about a compromise it would
entail players standing for the anthem
and protesting in some other context dak
prescott the cowboys quarterback making
31.4 million this year as a franchise
player he addressed the anthem yesterday
let's listen carefully to how dak
prescott tiptoes through this minefield
i think if anything you'll just see
guys expressing themselves and then more
so from that you're going to see people
supporting one another and loving one
another and then we'll all be working
toward a common goal which in the game
of football is winning but um in life i
think it's love and equality i can't say
that there's been one
direct answer or one direct way that
we're going to go about it but i sure
hope so uh that's what this country is
about the freedom to do that to freedom
and express yourself and
um as we have as we've heard mr jones
talk about grace uh and sharing grace
and having grace with players and what
they what they want to do so
if i had it my way that's exactly what
we do is express ourselves individually
but love and support one another
collectively
i really don't know what that means when
i saw the words in writing i thought one
thing when i hear him deliver it i i
think another when i saw it in writing
yeah right i i hear i i hear that he's
hoping that they all do one thing
together for the anthem but have other
ways to individually express themselves
is that how you're interpreting it i
heard that i i thought he was more or
less saying
hey if guys want to kneel just let them
kneel and let's be supportive and show
love for each other because it's their
right and then we'll all come together
with grace after that uh that's kind of
the way i took it there at the end maybe
i'm crazy i mean i know i am a little
i i know but there's just something
there
that that
i and and it was the last part of it
there was the way he said it that made
me think and and i'm influenced by the
background here because for the last
three years dak has been at the
forefront of saying we're gonna do what
we do as a team yeah and that there are
certain things we do as a team there are
certain things we do as individuals what
we do during the anthem is one of the
things we do as a team so i'm being
influenced by that background yeah okay
right yeah it's not so it's not cl he's
not coming out clearly and this is a
situation that does not call for nuance
either you are behind the idea of
players expressing themselves by
protesting during the anthem or you
aren't you cannot stake out a middle
ground here and i think that's what dak
was trying to do trying to find a way
yeah to thread the needle not in the
same way that jerry jones did he's
trying to thread the needle in a way
that he's trying to make jeffrey jones
feel good too yeah he's worried about
man jerry's the joneses are listening to
this i don't i don't want to sound like
a jerk
but that quote we have on the bottom of
the screen right now to me is where i
went ooh what you know i hope we can
express ourselves individually because
like you said the cowboys have been all
about team team team we're gonna do it
as a team we're gonna do it as a team
and i think that's the first time you
know a guy like dak prescott to kind of
come out and say that the hint at that i
that that to me tells me he's trying to
just send a nice
gentle
message to the jones family where like
if guys want to know let them kneel and
we're going to show that we all love
each other as soon as that's done and
that'll show grace that's the way i kind
of took it
and again the kneeling i think is going
to
potentially go by the wayside because
one of the questions is will there be
boycotts or wildcat strikes and we
talked yesterday about how troy vincent
the executive vp of football operations
essentially said they have the right to
sit out if they want to over social
justice issues which could be a huge
deal and chris i personally think and i
want to underscore this yeah
because we we've talked about the
messages that are going to be on the
field we've talked about the names on
the bumper at the back of the helmet we
may have the graphic we had it the other
day when peter king was on whether it's
george floyd brianna taylor ahmad arbury
whoever it is whose name is there
once that is out there for people to see
in the tens of millions
there is going to be i believe a
tremendous backlash there it is that's
what it's going to look like once we
start playing games and the casual fans
tune in next thursday night or all day
sunday sunday night monday night
whenever and they see in the close-ups
these names no doubt you are going to
hear it over and over again where are
the names of the police officers killed
in the line of duty where is david dorn
where is this person we know what the
the triggers are we know what the words
are we know what the phrases are
and
the nfl bracing for tweets from the
president based upon whether or not of
course
they need to be bracing for tweets from
the president on this this issue
definitely why are we honoring
these people and not police officers you
gave lives of course i mean what he does
is divide so he's going to send out many
objects
regardless of the parents you're right
they need to be ready for it you're
right well it's happening i mean listen
i could tell you there's already a
guinea pig out there i mean it's called
the nba i mean
i don't know
how many people have i've come across
for the last three weeks i can't watch
the nba anymore they're them and their
black lives matter crap like get the
hell out of here what are you talking
about of course they're gonna stick up
for black lives matter there's issues in
our country but you're right they're
gonna have to get worried about it it's
gonna turn some people off for sure
the other night game seven between
help me out here the nuggets and who who
the the jazz yeah the jazz
the jazz the new orleans jazz i mean the
utah jazz
there
was a rating of 3.3 million that watched
that game so
uh
so you take what the nba and that's a
good number in comparison to the past
first of all the numbers aren't dropping
for the nba even though some are
suggesting that no one's watching the
people who are saying i'm not going to
watch the nba weren't watching they
weren't watching anyways you're right
so you take the 3.3 million and you
multiply it by eight
right yeah and that's the crowd that's
going to tune in sunday night next week
when the cowboys and the rams get
together right so it's greater exposure
and greater exposure is going to result
in greater controversy and it's going to
be more attention it's going to be more
focused and my point is this we're
caught up in how people are going to
react to who stands and who doesn't
stand during the anthem
get ready
whatever side of this you're on whoever
you are in the league whatever job you
have you better have a plan if you're in
any sort of pr with teams and leagues
you better be ready to do something
because it is going to hit the fan and i
say that as objectively as i can we
support these efforts we think it's
appropriate we think it's proper but we
know
from fending off the folks who disagree
every day all day long on twitter
in the comments at profootballtalk.com
we know what's coming chris and i just
want to make sure everybody else out
there who's paying attention
has a little has a little part of their
brain set aside for this storm that's
going to begin once everybody sees those
helmets during games and begins to react
yeah no there's going to be a storm you
know just like there was in in you know
2016 and some of that too yeah we're
gonna have to deal with it it's gonna be
part of the sports conversation this
year the one thing that's different
though is i don't think the nfl cares
this year they're going to support you
know people of color social injustice
and their players more importantly and
that's where i want to tell that crowd
that wants to like you know rebuttal
against some of this stuff and all that
like tough then you won't be watching
football i don't know what else to say
and let me just say this and then we're
going to take a break if that's the case
then let's not run and hide when the
bully comes around and starts poking us
in the chest let's stand up to him nfl
let's see if they do that this time
around all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports